but there was one time that i act like i
thought he was sleeping so i quietly
fight
in the bed did he giggle he rolled over
he smelled it and he actually yelled at
me and he was like that is so [ __ ]
unattractive what
i've been with you for a year and i've
had to put up with this for a year in
the world same guy
no
yeah
[Music]
hello and welcome back to another
episode of big moves say you missed us
say it we don't know you missed us
today we have the beautiful the stunning
the one that looks like she's 18 forever
and ever and ever and ever nikki limo no
oh my gosh and then of course you guys
heard we have nikki and then there's me
gina hi hi gina hello today we are
talking about uh what married people
miss about being single and we have two
ladies here who are happily
i've been married and divorced twice
yeah she's been married divorced twice
and this is about to be in her actual
happily ever after after
a very healthy good relationship now and
i'm so excited for her yeah thank you
yeah and nikki is married to scumbag
steve i love him he's the best i love
him that's my nickname for him
he's the best
sweetheart steve he really is and i'm
holding it down for the uh non-married
single team the single team that's me so
you know you're doing it right thank you
got a good balance here yeah they both
have experience in being married anna we
found this uh list on buzzfeed of people
telling us what they miss most about
being single and you know or not being
married and i figured we'd go through it
oh i'm excited
i'm excited too because i'm really
curious about what the items are making
some sense yeah
it's my two years yeah i can't wait to
hear your thoughts too and you've been
through
several yeah and you have experiences
from both that are
right very valuable to share i think i
want to i want to get that from you and
i want to know like yeah yeah what your
expectations would be of if you were
married like am i normal for feeling
this way yeah okay and then um so i
haven't read through the article yet not
because i wasn't unprepared
we are always prepared always and i just
burped into the mic
that was just planned
so i wanted to read through it and for
it to be like the first time yeah very
natural i love that that's the best so
let's start the first one is
i miss
the quiet except for tv music or video
games it was so quiet in my house now
with the wife and three little girls
it's a mad house sometimes when it's
just me and the dog i look over and i
apologize to him
i'm so sorry scruffy
i have been in loud houses before
can't say our house is like that cats
are pretty quiet right we don't have
kids right so i don't know if that's a a
married thing as so much as a parent
thing
um jess you had a child that's true was
it wow yes i did and yeah
oh my god that's true like oh my god
that's right i did i had to try it um a
long time ago i'm living like both
worlds now because lacie is an
eight-year-old uh her
one of her very closest friends is also
gay and so it was her egg and they had a
surrogate and so we have magic baby
quinn who yes children are loud and very
energetic and then it's quiet so it is a
parenting thing for sure and then when i
had corrine all of my attention went to
her but i worked a lot so i don't even
know i blacked out
yeah i guess when i have kids i could
better relate to that i do enjoy quiet
i'm not and that's why i can't have a
dog i think because i always heard my
neighbors dogs and i i
like cats they're quiet quiet right
nibbler except for this one he's kind of
very vocal i love it nibbler yells at me
all the time yeah he touched me he's
very demanding he's the dog cat he is
but i don't mind him either i think he's
he could be a gateway to dogs
but were they quiet before is that my
thing because i'm pretty loud
women well women women in marriages oh
like i lacie's like you talk a lot like
you're yeah yeah i wouldn't noise it
yeah i definitely am i talk to myself
and i am i don't realize it um but he's
also tucked in a room like a way right
like i don't know like i feel like when
we [ __ ] when we had an apartment and we
both were working from home at the same
time because when we got together he
actually went to work and then
there came a time when we both worked
from home and that was weird it felt
like
i felt a little encroached on because i
like having a quiet house all the time
and like doing my whatever i do and like
that way if i have to cry or yell or
scream no one's like judging me too of
your own space because i guess i am loud
but i like everything else to be quiet
right um but um yeah he uh
he would clear his throat a lot and i
remember getting like annoyed annoyed at
it yeah and you're like why doesn't he
realize he does that and while he's
reading he's just always like
just old man noises oh and you're like
is this a twitch i'm so confused i'm not
gonna complain to him because it's i
don't want him to feel bad about it yeah
and then he's all self-conscious but i
just i'm like we need offices we
definitely need separate offices and i
think that's what it comes down to is
like the house is going to be loud with
little ones and where can you carve out
time for yourself yeah like also for
mental health yeah you know and you
definitely need to to have alone time
like eat whether that's going to the gym
or going on a walk around the
neighborhood you're locking yourself in
the closet and yeah snickers
no judgment the balance has to be there
for sanity purposes so how about you
casey like you came into
tiff and isaac does it ever feel like
it's like when it's like he's just never
quiet
it was
a lot to handle and comprehend he said
he's like me he enjoys quiet and sensory
they moved in with him it was just a lot
to process at a time
i totally agree with that you appreciate
it yes now in the quiet it's kind of
like oh it's a good thing it's a good
save casey yeah
you learn to appreciate it
that's a trained husband
uh okay so the next one says i miss when
things were where i left them
hi excuse me who touched the bread
who touched my snickers
i obviously have some trauma around
snickers yeah seriously like she has a
horde of snickers i think i can always
get your free birthday now i think
absolutely
sneakers yeah are you okay no
that's true because you maybe put
something down and then they picked it
up was it like a phone charger because
this has caused many of fights and
marriages oh you know what i mean
stop touching my phone charger that was
like a big point of contention joe's my
marriage yeah i'm like can you not take
my charger
again i'm kind of the opposite so i'm a
scatterbrained
crazy bird like i i put my keys down and
i'm like where did they go i just had so
much action
and steve always knows where they are
and i'm like it's so helpful to have
someone that knows where the [ __ ] i put
things down i know where everything is
and vice versa like he'll be like i
can't find my glasses i'm like they're
um under the shelf on the bed like um
under like on the by the sock that you
put there lift the notebook there they
will be there there they are yeah that's
me yeah lacy will misplace her phone or
her keys it's always the phone or the
keys yeah i always know where they are
yeah and i think that's such a good i
think that's the sign that's the one
that's the sign that that's the one if
you're losing something and they know
where you're going to find it that's the
one that's the one well i lose things
all the time so i guess it wouldn't
change very much for me it's a single
person but also earlier i was thinking
as a single person it is really nice to
just have my house completely silent
when i need it to be yeah yeah like i
whenever we go out or like i have work
or have friends all the time when i'm
going out with them it's nice to come
home and it's just
quiet and it's how you left it yeah no
one picked up anything and misplaced it
you know snickers um
ever since steve got his own like little
man cave because i like everything to be
a certain way i get to be decorated a
certain way i like things to be in a
certain place and it's mostly for my own
sanity because i will
create chaos wherever i go i'll make a
hurricane of objects wherever i go if
things don't have a system and so i
created these systems so that i can keep
my house tidy because otherwise it's
going to be a disaster and so um when
steve didn't have his little man cave
office the system would constantly be
getting [ __ ] with and i'm like i can't
my head is not it's not working and
nothing's working and then giving him
his own space he can mess up his space
as much as you want i never see it it
doesn't affect the other systems and i
think systems are ideal and so we have a
very happy marriage i was just gonna say
that comes down to communication too
because imagine if you weren't
communicative and he was messing with
your systems and you thought nothing's
working and then you projected that onto
your relationship where you're like
nothing's working we aren't working i
think that's what happens a lot of the
times is you can't figure out what the
problem is other than that
other than the variable that there's new
persons in your life right it's like you
can't really pinpoint what's driving you
up the wall so then you just start
blaming them for everything because
you're like this working it's just you
it's you um i put my body wash here you
took a shower you moved it we're done
yeah we're done
but then i think being aware of like
what is the thing the like exact thing
that they did break it down is throwing
you off and then you can yeah you work
backwards from there and if you're able
to communicate with that with them
usually if they care about you and they
love you they're like oh okay yeah no
we'll work around it like we'll figure
out a solution together and and those
are the building blocks of like a
foundation of a healthy relationship is
just learning how to
make each other's lives easier and
that's how you know they're the one too
that's true oh yeah the one shitty guy i
dated he had like a two sinks and it was
completely empty because he kept it
super nice and clean except for one side
he had a toothbrush and i just had to
use that side for the makeup because
there's a double mirror and he would
yell and say why can't you just do your
makeup on the other side i'm like all
you have to do is just take your
toothbrush and go ahead and move it over
because you just needed the sink yeah
and he's just a double-sided and i'm
like are you seriously starting a fight
over this and he goes oh yeah you're
right i'm like so that's good that's
good advice that's good nice
communication
look at us go us yeah
move your toothbrush we have some xp
yeah
um peaceful sleep i miss not being
beaten in my sleep by my wife i bought a
king-sized bed so you can fight your
dream ninjas on your side
stay away please and it's the snoring
that keeps me awake or wakes me up and
another person says sleeping in the
middle of a bed like a starfish also
eating in bed and having five pills to
myself is the best part of being single
and this is why a lot of older people
sleep in two separate beds yeah my
parents sleep in two separate bedrooms i
always thought it's because they don't
get along anymore but is this like a
marriage it's a it's a snoring
yeah it's like uh my dad said she my mom
snores so loud and he used to like start
kicking her like not hard but like you
know like yeah
and and that my mom would constantly be
woken up by him kicking her and then she
was like getting upset because she was
like oh
yeah yeah
and so they were getting into a lot of
fights over the sleep
over the sleep
so they they solved their problem by
switching rooms
earplugs for me in a sound machine
and i sleep like a sardine anyway this
is i sleep like a geisha so this is how
she's on my sprinkles she's a vampire oh
yeah that's me sleeping on my side it's
a genius why are you an angel even in
sleep that's not fair
i sleep like a drool machine and my face
is smushed into a pillow and it's just
drool
super sexy still he's like you sleep
like an angel it's because he can't see
my face because i'm turned away from him
but he just hears it he's like you don't
snore you just make this noise it's like
oh
and i'm like that's really cute you
sound like a freaking thunder mountain
and if i ever get woken up in the middle
of night i can't go back to sleep
but yeah guest rooms help oh okay yeah i
just sleep diagonal in my bed and then
my cat sleeps directly on my face
that suffocates me at night
well i mean i can't breathe so we got
panicking
or when i first brought him you like it
i do
when i first brought him home he would
wake me up every morning by stepping
directly in my throat so that's always
nice he's like mommy i heard you ask for
this
and he like doesn't see your boobs
and i see when he likes this
you're a good boy
number four says
money my money was my money to do
whatever i wanted with that's what they
miss about being single i think separate
finances can help a lot of marriages for
sure sure if there's one person that's
like too controlling over the finances i
don't understand that yeah um i can only
speak from other marriages that i've
heard of uh in my family like other
members of my family like they uh i
heard them talk about how like so and so
controls the finances and they want to
you know spend it on a vacation but the
their significant other wants to save
for retirement and they fight about it
all the time and i'm like oh i can't
imagine that because if i was
contributing to the finances i feel like
i should have a say in the finances
um again systems it's like i think if
you can establish systems very early on
in your relationship the better the
better yeah and and then you can see if
you're even compatible because there's
there's two components of a a good
relation a long lasting relationship in
my opinion it's uh compatibility is one
and then uh what's the chemistry is the
other so sometimes people have crazy
chemistry crazy chemistry but they're
not compatible in any other sense like
they fight over the finances they fight
over the the where things should go they
fight over everything else and sometimes
they're very compatible like on paper
they got everything
worked out they're very smart
they just don't like to [ __ ] each other
there's like i can't imagine kissing him
yeah it's like being married to you like
it's like and i feel like there's when
you listen to married couples there's so
there's two distinct ways to tell which
one it is like one will be like you know
marriage is like a business you know you
have to operate and you know the sex is
going to die and blah blah blah blah but
you keep going because it just works and
that's really what the how the society
runs and then the other people are like
this [ __ ] i [ __ ] hate him but i
can't live without him i [ __ ] gotta
be with him i don't understand like you
look at this [ __ ] is everywhere blah
blah blah but i got a [ __ ] standard
system i am like okay you guys are
chemistry you guys are compatibility but
you don't have both if you can find a
way to have both you will be in a very
good spot and that's also how you know
it's the one
and that's how you know it's the one
but um so yeah early on in our
relationship steve owed thirteen
thousand to the irs
and my dad's an accountant and he like
helped him out with that situation he
didn't pay for it a lot of people were
like nikki's dad bailed steve out no no
no see paid for it he just was able to
work it down a bit um but yeah steve
didn't know that like when you're a 1099
employed independent contractor that you
have to set aside your taxes yeah that
um they don't get taken out of your
paycheck for you and so he was very
shocked at the tax bill at the end of
the year and a lot of people do
encounter that problem and so um after
that initial going into the relationship
i was like okay i know how to manage
finances
you go make money i'll help you manage
the finances i'll figure everything out
anything he wants to buy he anything
over 500 we talk about it together so
big purchases we talk about together but
anything less than that he's free to buy
whatever he wants to buy i'm free to buy
whatever i want to buy we don't question
each other and then unless i'm like hey
we gotta kind of be a little bit more
stringent towards the this week for
until the end of the month just because
we're running low on this budget right
um he'll tighten up all tighten up but
other than that we don't really
you have a system in place
yeah everything's budgeted out we just
everything's on autopay
so it doesn't really it's not really
cumbersome right that's good uh let me
see number five says i miss taking off
and doing whatever the [ __ ] i want
whenever i want
yeah yeah i think i i have i always have
a life outside of my partner yeah and i
think that's really important it's
really healthy to flex your independence
because otherwise yeah you will miss
that and that's not ever something you
want to miss when your relationship
because then we go back to that thing
where it's like you're blaming them i
can't be myself or have fun with my
friends because you're here all the time
all these different also when you have
kids too because you can't just
see that's different parenting
a lot of these problems i feel like are
kid really like parent kid related
rather than marriage related because if
you have a healthy enough marriage where
you're able to communicate with your
partner about your needs and wants and
they respect you for it i don't think
you'll have any of these problems with
steve i we both are very independent and
i could not imagine telling him not to
do the things he wants to do during the
day and i can't imagine him like when i
was saying earlier when guys at the
poker table like your husband lets you
just play poker and like lets me like
in what world would i need permission
like i just can't fathom that that's a
thing i would never be with someone that
needed me to ask permission to do
something i want to do and vice versa
like if he wants to go out unless it's
like could i go to strip club every
night like obviously like we're going to
have a chat about that right that might
be over the 500 limit yeah yeah true
yeah it's out of our budget cool it down
but if it's like a it's a hobby it's a
skill it's something that you enjoy
doing like why the [ __ ] wouldn't you you
should be able to live just how you were
when you're single but as you are
married also you're supported right yeah
like there's someone adding some level
of enhancement enhancement to your life
and gina said this earlier like it's
between talking about parenting and
being single i really do think it comes
down to parenting and having to navigate
what does family time look like what
does couple time look like and what does
alone time look like and being okay with
having to navigate and manage time
management yeah that's a lot yeah time
management and boundary management
boundaries yeah
i think that's a lot to do with it but
yeah if you're out there right now and
your significant other is like
controlling what how you spend your free
time i would have a i would have a
conversation about that because it's you
should nip it in the bud right now you
should you don't want to live forever
with someone telling you how to spend
your free time rules on your own time do
you want to make it easy to refresh your
wardrobe with seasonal pieces that feel
like you well that's where stitch fix
comes in it's easy to get pieces to add
to your wardrobe whether it's date night
dresses or cozy loungewear or even this
i got this jacket that's like a coat but
then it also is a hoodie like it can be
dressed up or it could be dressed down
and i wear it with pretty much
everything jeans dresses everything i
love it stitch fix makes it so easy to
update your wardrobe with just a click
of the button okay here's what you're
gonna do you're gonna go to the website
you're gonna fill out a little quiz it's
gonna show you like different pictures
of things you just click on the pictures
that you like from there a stylist will
curate a specific style for you and then
they'll send you some pieces that go
along with that style and you pick the
ones you like send back the rest it's
the easiest way to get items that are
just right for you from brands that you
know and trust like madewell and
sanctuary and you get looks that are
just exactly perfect for you so get
started today by filling out your
freestyle quiz at stitchfix.com
big mood and take advantage of free
shipping and returns that's
stitchfix.com bigmood to try stitch fix
stitchfix.com
bigmood today's episode is sponsored by
honey the easy way to save when shopping
on your iphone or computer thanks to
honey manually searching for coupon
codes is the thing of the past honey is
the free shopping tool that scours the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best one it finds to your cart so here's
how it works uh when you're shopping on
one of your favorite sites at checkout
the honey button appears and all you
have to do is click apply coupons wait a
few seconds as honey searches for
coupons you can find for that site and
if it does find a working coupon you'll
watch the prices drop i've actually been
using honey since they started
sponsoring us years ago and it's been so
useful because i don't have to think
about using the app it just pops up by
itself and it starts looking for all the
best coupons even like the most obscure
coupons and applies it and i've been
saving money i think one time i was
shopping for clothes i don't remember
which site but it found a coupon for
like 20 off new shoppers which it wasn't
advertised anywhere on the page but
honey found it and i got to save money
if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting this show get honey
for free at
joinhoney.com big mood that's join
honey.com
big mood the next one is uh i miss not
having to justify myself to another
adult if i'm getting take out two days
in a row what no i would never you sound
like controlling poverty all right
this is borderline abusive like where if
someone's like so possessive of you that
you're gonna get in trouble yeah if you
ever have to go in the car and order
food
and eat it so yeah just how you don't
want to get in trouble yeah they're i
don't know that they're the person for
you yes
and there's a difference like okay i
don't know enough details about this
person's situations but there's a
difference if you've had a conversation
like hey your partner's like hey you
don't have a job and we're running low
on finances we can't eat out very often
i gotta cook from home and then you
order takeout two days in a row then
that's different because it's a health
thing you're like yeah exactly you're
putting something else in jeopardy like
another part of your life in general in
jeopardy and they love you and they want
you to be around or if it's like you're
having heart surgery tomorrow and
they're like really you're gonna just
have a whopper yeah yeah yeah the night
before okay then okay conversation but
if that's not something if it's just
like a regular thing you both are adults
and you're both making money and you're
both decide and you won't decide you
want to have takeout that should take
out the justification
yeah uh the next one is i miss the
excitement of first dating someone you
like i vividly remember the last time i
got butterflies before i kissed someone
for the first time there is definitely
something about the excitement of
meeting someone the anticipation when
you actually schedule time to spend
together and then the moments before the
deep dive into something physical don't
get me wrong i'm a big sap so it's her
i'd like to experience it with again but
yeah it'd be so nice that we live those
feelings again this is why you have to
continue to court your partner
absolutely one thousand percent we talk
about this all the time all the time
tell you um you definitely have to have
a date night at least once a week at
least once a week i would say once a
week but if you can't if you can't do
that at least once a month you but you
have to have
a date night a specific date night
carved out and that's not watching tv on
the couch that's like going out dressing
up getting nice like going on a date a
proper date looking good for each other
looking good for each other having good
conversation having a few drinks having
whatever it makes you too learning
finding something new together i think
discovering new things together is our
favorite thing to do it's exciting it's
like going to a new place that you've
never been to i love hearing his opinion
on it he loves hearing my opinion on it
we like are both processing new
information together keeping it spicy
new experiences yeah it makes me really
sad when because it's very easy for
couples to once they get married they're
like well there's nothing left from here
and so they get really comfortable and
routine it really wanes the relationship
and it's sad i remember there was a rule
that i learned about the 2-2-2 rule
which is you go on a date every two
weeks go on like a trip every two months
and go on a like um vacation out of
country every two three years to keep oh
i like that yeah nice yeah
we used to um do a rule because we i
mean i guess it depends on what your
love language is but um we value
experiences more than things so
we didn't get each other presents at all
no birthday anniversary valentine's no
no presents no christmas presents but
once a year we'd go on a lavish vacation
like for a week you know get away and
just experience a new part of the world
together and we loved that but then the
pandemic happened yeah so
we got a a robot bartender
investment and pretended we were on
vacation
i like that that is a vacation yeah
we had a projector screen out there it
was like we were just watching survivor
in the jacuzzi with
robot bartender drinks
with your like mai tai like it's like
you know they're on an island and it's
like we're on an island
uh the next one is i miss being alone
and not feeling guilty i have a wife and
daughter so when i do get a chance to be
alone for a couple hours it's amazing as
hell but i feel bad that i want to be
alone i love them both to death and
would do anything for them but man i
miss my alone time i think that's so
important like independence my long-term
relationships i would tell them
sometimes like hey i just need a date to
myself
and literally that date to myself is
just me [ __ ] off on bed and watching
anime right you know
eating snacks crumbs everywhere like you
just need that alone time and i think
it's hard for
extroverts to understand sometimes
because
introverts like you me and gina are both
more introverts than extroverts but you
a lot of people can't tell because we're
like you know we're out there when we're
having fun we're having fun you're
introverted extroverts yeah we're like
we're socializing like we're here our
energy's here we're giving it but it's
draining like after that night it's like
the battery went to ten percent and we
have to charge it back in by being alone
and that's the only way we charge and so
a lot of people that are extroverts
don't understand that like they're like
okay
you're not going to talk to anyone like
no like what are you gonna do like alone
like what do you even do
i just like to be alone with my thoughts
social batteries definitely is a thing
and lacy's is more introverted she's
also extroverted and people wouldn't
know that about her but she is more
introverted and i would say she's more
introverted than me and she values her
alone time so on days where i'm here and
i'm like doing things where i'm gone for
the day you know she can sit on the
couch and watch sports or go to the
beach alone and drive do whatever she
wants
to recharge and re-center herself and it
made me realize that i also value alone
time yeah and i just never gave myself
the opportunity see i think introverts
and extroverts they both need the same
things it's just that the difference is
what they get recharged by so steve he's
an extrovert and we both like alone time
but he gets charged by being around
other people right he gets super charged
by like talking to people and being
there and i love being around people
sure but i get charged by being alone
yeah
and so that's those are just the main
differences it a lot of people think
that introvert means shy it doesn't like
people that are introverts it doesn't
necessarily mean they're like they're
closed off and they're shy and they
don't know how to talk to people it just
means that that's how they charge is
being alone yeah you you and steve is
how lacey and i operate i think that's
great it's a good balance it's a great
balance because then when he'll he'll
just like sometimes go out and i'm like
great he gets to go out and even if he's
quiet at home i still feel his energy
totally and so when he leaves the house
and like goes to socialize and i get the
whole house alone it's like we both are
getting what we need to recharge it's
great yeah
there's i remember like dating people
who's like when i tell them i need some
you know just a day i'll feel like what
do you mean like you don't want to hang
out with me and they take it personally
right there's nothing to do with them
yeah it's like sucks i hate when that
happens yeah exactly it's like well you
have a day off why don't you want to
spend it with me it's like dude
let me chill for a second i want to give
you the best of me exactly i think
that's what they don't understand so you
have to get back to this is how i give
you a better version of me is by like
letting myself charge yeah and i
actively offer it to them too because
like there are times when i'm like when
you're newly dating someone you want to
see them all the time but yeah i offer
it to them too like do you want to date
to yourself like i don't have to come
over anything too like i try to be
mindful of that too because people need
their alone time it's great that you're
mindful of that that's so great
uh the next one says i miss cleaning the
way that i want i have a thing about
liking to clean when no one else is
around just because how i do it takes
time and has a weird system to it i hate
being observed while i clean i don't
want to hear that i miss a spot i don't
want to hear their method of cleaning i
don't want to hear anything i want to
put my earphones in and just enjoy
cleaning
oh
i've never had two cleaners in a
relationship me either and i'm the
cleaner i enjoy cleaning i have ocd and
i i think there's a method
i feel like if i was cleaning and
someone said hey you missed the spot i
will punch them yeah totally yeah
and i don't support domestic violence
yeah but don't [ __ ] tell me i missed
a spot right now pointed out wind it up
in my head i punch you
so yeah you're the cleaner i know your
house is always spotless and beautiful
and you've been like my inspiration for
oh my god sometimes i go over and i'm
like that's how you organize that
oh
oh so my house is a [ __ ] nightmare
for you right now no no it's when it's
my personal space like the way that i
um
take stress off of myself and i recharge
like blast music and i clean how crazy
does that sound it doesn't sound crazy
anymore because i never used to be a
clean a cleaner person but um once that
system is in place it's all about
systems i swear like if you can figure
out a system that works for you it'll
organize your whole head and make you
feel so good um i love putting on music
and cleaning but it takes like three
hours yeah and i need like to go one
room at a time one room at any time i
don't like people walking through the
room while i'm cleaning like you just
stepped into the pile that i was
sweeping yeah and he's not observing me
and he's not like commenting on it but
if i'm cleaning the kitchen and then he
goes and makes a meal i'm like
great i was just cleaning it
i could have had an enjoyable day
i figured out my own system right so
that's exactly i hired people yeah
it's my system i know i know my
witnesses and i know how to remedy them
yes
um i miss friends don't get me wrong my
wife has done nothing to isolate me but
when you marry your soul mate it's easy
to think that's all you'll ever need add
a long hour's job to the mix and before
you know it she's the only person you
interact with away from the desk
then kids come along and you'd sacrifice
anything for your family especially free
time but the kids grow up and your wife
craves time away from you and the kids
then one day you realize you're alone
that's what my parents are going through
they're like
wow we uh
we have to like come home and there's no
kids and um we don't know what to talk
about oh i mean they love each other you
know but they just
they're like
sometimes we run out of things to talk
about it's like how did you sleep last
night uh
not good i mean either
food oh yeah me too
oh uh
so-and-so is coming over later to check
out the the leak on the sprinkler oh
okay exciting whoa i think that all
comes down to right date nights yeah
date nights again and also
remaining independent of your partner
and having a life outside of them having
hobbies having hobbies figuring out like
what you're passionate about what lights
you up outside of your relationship and
having the conversation where you can
you communicate early on that it's
really important that you both
have independent lives outside one
another because then not only are you
guys both recharged but you also have
something to talk about when you get
together you're like oh my god you'll
never believe this like lately it's been
a lot of like me telling their crazy
conversations at the poker table and
like there's a lot of characters and i
think it's hilarious and i think steve
would really enjoy them and so i tell
them i tell them all about it and we
have a blast together and then he tells
me like about his bar friends that he
met and like what create they're always
like starting some crazy businesses and
stuff and we just like have a blast
talking to each other about what we did
without each other and that's the thing
because you spent time away when you're
with someone 24 7 you don't need to ask
about their day because you know their
day mm-hmm you were their day you were
you're the whole day you're the whole
work
um i also think it's we're i'm in a kind
of unique situation where we have a lot
of mutual friends like steve and i got
together and we were in the same
friendship group and so like jess knew
both of us independently before we got
together and i met jk independently of
steve and then he met them later and so
it's like we are all kind of you know in
a mixed group like i don't think there's
a single friend that besides my high
school friends like i don't think that
there's friends that we have outside of
of each other and not on purpose it's
just like we work together we play
together we everything's together but we
do have our hobbies where we meet other
people that's the best that's fun uh
let's see the next one says i miss not
having to consider anyone else when
making a decision someone once said
being married is just asking another
person what they want to eat for dinner
until one of you dies
i guess like i kind of
enjoy that when i get out of a
relationship because now i'm just like i
can do whatever the [ __ ] i want and not
have to worry about well what are you
doing this weekend do you want to get
you know like i'm just like i just do
whatever the [ __ ] i want now yeah you
can be selfish when you're single right
you're more selfish with your time where
you're not like i think something that
would happen in uh my marriage was that
they would be making something for
themselves and wouldn't ask if i wanted
and then i'd be like oh but i really
wanted that's weird so yeah that's weird
because i know you cooked a lot for your
ex um too yeah so that wouldn't even be
a thought done to ask in your mind um i
think a lot of people want to be to flex
being selfish that's not the time yeah
yeah right yeah you know in our marriage
um it's i don't it's not that like where
it's like
because i've heard that that meme before
um it's more just like are you hungry
and usually our hunger cycles are off
and i was like oh i just ate oh okay
i'll make something or vice versa and
then if we are hungry at the same time
it's like oh what sounds good to you and
it feels like we're kind of like
choosing an adventure together
like okay wanna try out this restaurant
now i don't know it might it sounds like
it's too filling okay i have something
lighter okay so how about how about this
one it's like ooh that kind of sounds
good and then we just kind of get it but
yeah we make it fun i think like keep
things fun yeah keep things on adventure
keep things like new and interesting and
routine's the enemy it's not exciting
yeah you have your system for the boring
things like cleaning like
a system to make it fulfilling but the
like the partner stuff like that needs
to keep that fun keep it fun and light
it's different keep it going yeah keep
there being things to talk about things
to do together and if you want to be
i i want to be selfish with my time
sometimes and you want to be alone and
you want to not you want to order food
for yourself and not have to worry about
anybody then schedule a night where they
do something with their friends or on
their own and then you have that time to
be like what do i want yeah and
communicate like that communication huge
thing as communication is everything
because if you have an
understanding loving partner it
shouldn't be scary to communicate your
needs to them to say like hey i kind of
want a night alone is that cool yeah and
then they're like yeah okay they should
the answer should be [ __ ] yeah yeah
always it should be that um and
everything if not there should be like
some crazy reason why it's not and
they're like i had a surprise dinner
planned yeah yeah
or like oh my mom's actually coming over
is it okay if you just like if you use
entertainment for two hours yeah your
night tomorrow night or something i'm so
sorry yeah you have a compromise but
yeah for the most part
it should feel
more free than a lot of people
tell you it is um
i just kind of feel like there's this
notion that marriage is
this like ball and chain like this
traditional
like yeah the old school like the guy
makes the money the woman's the
homemaker and you guys are just [ __ ]
trapped and like good good luck you know
have kids and die and like it just is so
sad and it really doesn't have to be
that way in this modern era where anyone
is free to make the as much money as
they want uh like have kids or not have
kids get married or don't get married
like you have a lot of freedoms and so
if you're gonna choose something like
marriage to commit yourself to then you
better be sure that you guys [ __ ]
understand each other and like it yeah
like you like each other and you like
the system you have together because
it's now a legal thing that's very hard
to get out of so it shouldn't be
something you feel like you're settling
on like definitely now i'm trapped in
this so i gotta figure it out and make
it work because it's too expensive to
leave and i have to ask them what they
want to eat for dinner yeah yeah until
when he dies until one of you dies and
if this is you and you're having this
like just have conversations with each
other so that this isn't you so it's not
a thing it doesn't have to be hard it
doesn't have to be torture yeah to be
together i always thought that trope was
so weird like you know people have
wedding cake toppers where it's like the
woman's dragging the boy the wife the
bride is dragging the the groom that was
our wedding cake oh my gosh
it was because he played xbox all the
time and i had to plan the whole wedding
and i was like usually to play xbox and
he's like i'll help i was like i don't
even know what to tell you to help with
because i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
doing and so
he our our engagement photos were um him
playing video games and me trying to
seduce him and then that's right and
then me playing video games and him like
pissed off and then our wedding cake
topper it was customized from etsy and
it was him playing grand theft auto
which was the game he was playing and
drinking a coke zero which was what he
drank
and me trying to drag him
away from it but it's that's more like
dragging him away from the xbox yeah old
like the old like balling chain
yeah like um force him to get maribel
he's trying to run away like the woman's
always forcing me to get married like he
said when it's
like true when people are like that's so
true that's so
bad it should be a joke it should be a
big fat joke yeah yeah
i've noticed that like the worst um
engagement posts on instagram from you
know it's a very problematic couple when
this the post starts with we've had our
ups and downs oh
geez but here we are yeah we went
through the worst but we made it so yeah
we're
happy for them like you know if you
worked it out and you resolved some
really underlying resentment and now
you're like on a fresh page that's great
um but a lot of times they say that when
they're not coy yeah exactly
they're still working and they just want
to plan a wedding yeah yeah that's what
people say they don't want to get
married they just want a wedding but
people just want that's what i want for
you i don't care if you get married just
[ __ ] have a wedding for me gina
don't be selfish but it doesn't even
need to be selfish yeah that doesn't
even need to be a groom i'm just a
freaking fish in a fishbowl i don't care
something
[Applause]
uh the next one says i miss traveling
alone i mean i can travel alone if i
wanted to but it would feel kind of mean
to be like hey i want to plan a really
big cool trip and you're not invited
this tip went to a different sepurapora
but that was different because she had
never been alone in her life and so she
kind of needed like a come to jesus like
where like she got to experience that
for once because uh she was a teen mom
and she was had a boyfriend or a husband
and had had isaac and then she was with
isaac the entire adult life her entire
life and then she was with casey and it
was like she never experienced traveling
alone being alone doing anything alone
she felt almost like she couldn't maybe
she couldn't be alone and i think she
needed to know
okay i can be alone now that i have that
i'm happy i have my family yeah i can
appreciate it it helps you appreciate
your family more don't think too much of
one thing maybe does drive people insane
so too much aloneness makes people want
to be with someone too much of being
with someone making people want to be
alone
if you can just create balance in your
life um you'll you won't
feel like this is a
problem from your partner right you know
like i think it's just a lot of things
there's people not voicing their needs
right the balances the systems in place
and communication yeah i used to go away
for new year's um just on a loan trip
like just alone for three days like i'd
plan a vacation somewhere and be there
alone and it was great it's like a
really reflective thing and it's
beautiful and you get to just like melt
away all the stress so it's yeah that's
just ask for it yeah
uh the next one says
i could go without all the rank ass
farts
my husband farts sounds like there's a
man playing the trombone trapped inside
of him i hate them they're so [ __ ]
loud but at least they don't smell so i
guess i have to count my blessings they
don't smell
i know that you and steve have a very
strict no bathroom sounds no farts no
whatever
each other and you and tiff too right
yeah gotten slack for the sea like and i
think it's i'm i've been won over
because um even though people comment
like that's you know you should be
comfortable with your partner blah blah
blah look i was on your team i totally
get what you're saying i used to say
that i used to be like well it just
means you're comfortable around each
other that's an old meme how many
couples do you know that are old and
married and they fart around each other
a lot and they hardly ever have sex yeah
that's not sexy and like you got to keep
some level of mystery
magic and so steve came into my our
relationship like yo i have one rule we
don't fart around each other
it was steve's idea yeah i had i was on
the other side i was on the like oh
we've always farted around each other
like in relationships once you get
comfortable enough and i had to ask him
it was like because you're is it because
you're not comfortable around me or is
it because he's like no
i got one piece of advice from a married
friend that still bangs his wife a lot
and it was that he
they don't fart around each other they
don't poop around each other they don't
pee around each other they keep bathroom
life private and they still finding each
other very sexually attractive right and
he's like i'll never forget that and i
will i really want to keep the magic
alive and i was like i've never tried it
but in every relationship the sexual
desire has gone down and we have farted
around each other so maybe there is some
congruency to that i will try your
method and see if it works it works and
so far i am more attracted to him than
ever
i don't know
and he's you know he he's getting older
and getting way more attractive to me
mm-hmm so i've always not farted in
front of my significant others but i did
date one guy that had ibs and he was
just he did not get it but he didn't
hide it all either like he didn't try to
at all so like about the intent yeah
we'll just be laying in bed and
this rank ass smell like dude did you
fart he's like yeah i'm like why didn't
you warn me he goes oh yeah sorry i was
just like oh no
like it gets annoying after a while you
know because then you're offended yeah
that stinks it's
subconsciously makes you less attracted
to them yeah you know it's not even a i
don't even think it's a conscious thing
because in my head with my ex-boyfriends
i was like i don't know like i never
associated it with the fart but i think
there is like a because they become more
brotherly yeah like who else does that
in fact my brother my brother does that
in front of me so and am i attracted to
my brother no so
you kind of start subconsciously
becoming my brother or
i'm like dude like it's like
consideration you know absolutely crack
a window yeah i hate when they think
it's funny too exactly it's not funny
like we're not 12. but there was one
time that i act like i thought he was
sleeping so i quietly thought
in the bed did he giggle was it no he
rolled over
no he yeah he rolled over he smelled it
and he actually yelled at me and he was
like that is so [ __ ] unattractive
what
i've been with you for a year and i've
had to put up with this for a year and
the world was the same guy
no yeah
and the windows were up the recent one
like it turned into a full-on argument
he's like that's [ __ ] disgusting
that's so weird yeah
so weird yeah it was mean that's me he's
so mean and also just like hypocritical
how does he not see that that
nurses what
and hello you thought he was sleeping
you were trying exactly right exactly it
was wild if you do it that's not that's
yeah no yeah also you do those in your
sleep too so yeah yeah it just happens
we don't even know it it's wild what do
you want to eat tonight maybe you want a
home-cooked favorite but don't feel like
going to the store or you want something
exciting and new but it would be great
to stay in tonight doordash connects you
with everything you want whenever and
however you want it get what you want to
eat right now and right to your door
with doordash along with the restaurants
you love you can now get groceries and
other essential items delivered with
doordash get drinks snacks and other
household items in under an hour craving
late night ice cream forget that one key
ingredient for dinner or maybe you just
need to stock up for the week with
doordash get everything in one app with
over 300 000 partners you can support
your neighborhood's go-to's or choose
from your favorite national restaurants
like popeyes chipotle and cheesecake
factory ordering is easy and your items
will be left safely outside your door
when you choose contactless delivery
which is awesome because then i don't
have to make myself like a decent human
being whenever they drop it off for a
limited time our listeners can get 25
off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15 or more when you
download the doordash app and enter code
big mood that's 25 off up to 10 value
and zero delivery fees on your first
order when you download the doordash app
in the app store and enter code big mood
don't forget the code is big mood for 25
off your first order with doordash
subject to change terms to apply
bone apple tea do you feel overwhelmed
when shopping for skin care there's like
so many items out there so many trends
so many ingredients don't you just want
someone trustworthy to be like hey don't
stress this is what you need and this is
why it'll work for your skin well that's
why custom rx treatment from row derm
was created it's personalized
prescription skin care that's designed
with dermatologists to help you reach
your goals like getting clearer smoother
healthier skin may happen younger skin
oh you don't think that's possible it is
have you heard of some of this new
technology okay well all you have to do
is complete a 10 minute online visit to
share your concerns like acne fine lines
wrinkles dark spots you name it all of
the above and then also you're gonna
like tell them some of your medical
history and the visit's free and i love
that you can do it without even leaving
your home because i don't like changing
out of pajamas if appropriate a us
licensed healthcare professional will
prescribe a custom rx treatment that
makes sense for your skin so it's made
with a blend of dermatologist selected
ingredients tailored to your needs and
right now new members will receive a
30-day trial of custom rx treatment plus
rhodarm's hydrating cleanser and
protecting spf lotion for just five
dollars when you go to rowderm.com
forward slash big mood shipping is free
and you'll get free and unlimited
follow-ups with your health care
provider to support you through your
skin care journey if you're prescribed
get your first month of custom rx
treatment plus rhoderm's hydrating
cleanser and protecting spf lotion for
five dollars so go to rowdurm.com
forward slash big mood
roadderm.com
big mood uh the next one says i miss
controlling the remote at all times
watching anything without constant
streaming commentary
oh yeah
we don't really watch a lot of tv in my
house that's either i can't imagine if
the tv was actually i can my ex did that
like he needed to have background noise
at all times
and i lived in a studio and we lived
together in a studio
and so there's no room to escape to too
much noise there's just a lot of noise
at all times and i i yeah it drove me
nuts and like when he was gone i was
like the silence
do you
i remember um like during dating like
when you're just getting to know people
i was getting to know this guy and every
time we came over he was like i really
want to watch prison break so we just
watched prison break all the time but
i'm like i'm kind of bored of the show
um can we change it he's like and he's
he threw a fit what he's like no i don't
like white like i want to finish prison
break blah blah like i'm like all right
peace out yeah you're not going to work
out yeah it's not going to yeah no if
you can't compromise it's just not going
to work i'm going to say it's all about
compromise i love rom-coms and
i'm a rom-com girl and lacey loves uh
like mysteries and and thrillers i like
those too yeah and i don't can i just
sit in the middle of youtube
so we compromise on those days i'm like
i won't look and you can tell me when
it's over
and then i make her watch like hallmark
with me yeah oh
yeah lifetime tv yeah oh i love a
lifetime yeah steve doesn't like
cartoons like any animation and i love
animated that's adorable
like pixar movies and stuff and uh but i
did make him watch wreck-it ralph with
me and he had to admit that he liked it
um and he did and he's like the writing
was really good i was like yeah see it's
not just like some
cartoon kids movie okay and uh he really
likes action movies and i don't i don't
like action movies do you compromise
yeah we both watch each other's [ __ ] and
um sometimes i admit like oh that was
actually a pretty good movie like they
had a plot line it's not just like bang
bang bang
yeah everything explodes for no reason
michael bay movies i ate a cake it
exploded like he loves die hard and i'm
like he made me watch and i was like oh
he's such a dude
also too if you compromise and you give
it a chance you might just like it you
might like it yeah that's what i don't
get when people get angry or mad or put
up such a fight it's like what are you
scared of you might like it yeah come on
please the answer is something yeah why
something you're so stubborn for no
reason yeah
uh and the last one here says i miss not
having to share my leftovers when i was
single i can treat myself to chinese
food and the leftovers were mine now i
have to be considerate and share it's
terrible what again boundaries yeah my
leftovers are yours i don't like people
having my leftovers yeah i don't like
leftovers so i'll give you my leftovers
oh i love it
really yeah for someone who eats like a
starving raccoon i know
he just he i'm like are you a snob like
why don't he's like i just don't i just
don't want to eat it's leftover food
it's not it's not fresh food i don't
like to eat it i'm like then why'd you
bring it home because he'll still bring
it home and like why did you bring it
home and we used to i used to eat his
leftovers but
now i'm a pescetarian and he's a meat
eater still and i
can't eat his leftovers so just it's a
waste i'm like
i don't know why you order so much food
then this man cooks his chicken until
it's ash yeah i think he likes the taste
of an ashtray garbage can a fresh one
and and so some some chef prepared food
is not not good
no not up his alley i never finished my
food i always i'm a grazer throughout
the day so i end up taking the the food
home and then it's perfect because lacie
loves leftovers and so she'll eat them
but if i bring something home yeah that
i want like chocolate cake
like you said nikki it's it's boundaries
and it's like don't you dare touch my
[ __ ] yeah she's a dessert she's a
dessert monster yeah like every time she
comes over she's like i'll bring dessert
i have i've got no she's gonna she's
gonna bring it
there was a phase we went through where
she would always come over and we'd go
to the grocery store and get cinnamon
rolls and then bake cinnamon rolls and
it was so we'd watch movies and like eat
cinnamon rolls it was delicious and so
good there weren't leftovers then no
one of my biggest pet peeves when i was
in a relationship was i always share my
food you know like if i'm eating
something i'm always going to share it
and they take the most giant [ __ ]
bite
oh the biggest of the best bites yeah or
like do you want some of my drink and
then they finish it and i'm like
what the [ __ ] and this is why we're
sorry
that's not cute yeah what the [ __ ] man
the only time that steve and i have had
and it wasn't even real arguments is
just like yo
dude like stop what the hell um was when
like we would get an appetizer like that
we'd share together and let's say
there's like four
cauliflower or let's say there's like
four of the thing that comes in like
four egg rolls
he eats three of them and then i get the
one and i'm like i thought this was a
partnership
i wanted that extra egg no it's not fair
is when they only put five egg rolls oh
yeah and there's two of you and you're
like can you just make it even because
now we have to figure out who's gonna be
he's like
and i still ate the one
or like i um i ordered egg rolls that's
why egg girls are popping up because i
ordered egg rolls as like i like to get
like a side if because i don't know if
the main dish is going to be big enough
like because sometimes in a new
restaurant you just don't know so i'm
like okay i'm going to get eagles on the
side and the main dish was big enough so
i didn't eat the eggs yet but i was like
i'm gonna have those tomorrow it's gonna
be sick
and i go to put them in the fridge and
it's an empty container and i'm like
where the [ __ ] did those ankles go and
he's like oh i hate them i'm like did
you order across he's like i thought
they were cape for free
oh my god boundaries steve boundaries
they'll come for free who gives eggs for
free
[ __ ]
what restaurant does that you wanted
though i don't know i thought it came
with my meal you thought it came with
your shoes yeah
who keeps on playing egg rolls those are
expensive to me i know there was like a
large portion it wasn't like little mini
ones that come on the side of it they
were full-blown full
for the most part like i don't really
care
when whenever that happens like the big
bite thing but there was one time what
happened like three times that week and
i just
i couldn't i could handle it it's it's
not a big thing you know uncrustable oh
yeah yeah
and like those are because they're tiny
bit right in the middle where the
best part is
yeah he's like can i take the best part
of your meal i was like and i looked i
was like what the hell like the first
couple times he's like oh sorry babe
it's not cute and then the third time
he's like why do you keep getting
[ __ ] mad over this and i'm like
dude anything love to put it on us yeah
always like like i always see the memes
like when your girlfriend knows to take
a bite and she eats the whole thing like
you know it's [ __ ] you but it's you
you stop projecting it
[Applause]
we never had that but um there was a
really weird thing we had in the
beginning that it took years to come to
light um when we first started dating i
if i wanted a bite of his food he'd give
me a bite vice versa whatever except for
when i wanted a bite of his burrito once
he wouldn't do it he wouldn't let me
have a bite of his burrito and i was
like what the [ __ ] did you just say just
give me a bite and we got actually got
into a little bit of an argument because
not about the burrito but just like why
like why won't you let me have a brand
he's like it's gross it's like you know
burrito i don't know it's wet and like
you know drool gets in there i'm like
drooling
how are you
eating drooling you're asian you're
wrong yeah
and like how the [ __ ] would you think
i'm gonna backwash your burrito yeah
like what the [ __ ] and so every time
like because i forgot a couple times
about the burrito thing and so i would
ask him for a bite and he's like not
with burritos and he was just like took
this stand against having a bite of his
burrito and then like speed forward to
like five six years go by we're well
into our marriage he's eating a burrito
and um and i'm like i know you don't
want me to have a bite of that but i
really want to try it but can i cut it
or like you know like have a bite he's
like dude you could have a [ __ ] bite
oh he's like i don't know what my
problem was
i had a weird thing one time like where
i just thought i had to take a stand in
the beginning of our relationship
because my ex and like i just had a lot
of like weird boundary issues and and
then after i did it the first time i
felt like i had to keep up because it
was like the burrito and not like not
the burrito it was like about the
burrito and so i just kept go it going
and i'm so sorry about that like i don't
have a thing about burritos
that is a long standing day
for years they went like for like the
first two years of our relationship i
was like he's really [ __ ] weird about
burritos we had a fight about it like a
few times i can't have a bite and like
yeah because i would forget because he
shared all of his other food but just a
[ __ ] burrito wouldn't let me have a
bite and he's like made up this whole he
was getting
upset that i would backwash his blood
but then he needed to stand by it yeah
and then he's like [ __ ] i need to i need
to commit i gotta get out of here
i don't think i've ever
said no to anyone like friend
significant other or family that's asked
for some of my food i just don't know
how to say no yeah it's like like how
would you say no it won't be my
justification for that right no no i
want it i've never said no i don't think
i would ever say no now but i was kind
of a drum freak when i was a kid
and um especially with like ice cream
like you know when like like yeah kind
of lick your ice cream cone or your
lollipop yeah like okay yeah
that feels singular yeah and i wouldn't
eat i wouldn't eat it if my mom licked
my ice cream i'm like
that's an unspoken rule that i assume
everyone knows though you don't ask to
lick someone's ice cream
right thank you no you don't i wouldn't
be sucking on a lollipop and be like you
want something yeah exactly my aunt
thought it was really funny if i was
eating a popsicle to come along and bite
the tip of it and i was like
yeah i can't eat it now
i would jokingly like if i was dating
someone that i would jokingly just like
eat my lollipop and i'd be like
see that's funny
that it's funny though yeah but like i
don't i think it's an unspoken rule like
you don't ask someone for that you know
yeah you wanna know the grossest thing
though
so i had this thing like with the saliva
thing i couldn't handle it and then in
seventh grade um we go on eighth grade
we go on this like class trip to
washington dc is like for like spring
break and like you're learning about
like our nation's history blah blah blah
and it was only like you know a few like
a like a classroom full of kids our age
that got to go and um my crush was there
and he had no idea that i liked him like
we weren't in any classes together he
was in the other class and like we got
to like you know be in hotel rooms and
like we're on the whole trip together i
kept trying to sit next to him and we
got went to this candy shop where you
get like rock candy rocky and so the
swizzle sticks and like so i was like i
was you know eating it and then he's
like can i have some it's a swizzle
stick you know it's all saliva yeah oh
[ __ ] crush so it was like no no and
he like like
i gave it back and i was like
and like it's like we kissed
but i was like that was the first and
only time i even shared a lot ever
shared a lollipop or an ice cream or
anything and i was like this is gross
but also it's you oh but the things we
do for love
yeah it's very particular
because it gets all in the crevices yeah
it's like it's like you're slurping up
you know
drool in general like we talked about
like oral sex like i don't like drool
like just at all that's the only time i
love joel like saliva a lot of people do
and it's very normal but for some reason
i just can't handle it like i picture it
no
going down my ass crack and i just
i just can't handle the
viscosity of it yeah yeah
no
and and steve's very good at not
backwashing yeah so i don't know how he
eats a burrito but if it's anything like
he eats up my pajamas you shouldn't
watch that burrito worry about it yeah i
remember like sharing drinks wise like i
remember when i was little my uncle
would share my drink with me
and then when he pulls like the straw
drink out there's like a trail of jewels
yeah i'm just like yeah you can hold on
to that you can keep that it's yours now
that's yours i don't want to see the
drool or the spit you know like if i
don't see it yeah it's probably fine
it's not there yeah yeah but they say
that um the last sip of any beverage is
50 saliva
sorry like ever since i learned that and
that might not be true i learned this
when i was a kid and it stuck with me
forever
it might not be true at all but i have
never been able to drink the last sip of
a drink children do backlash
i think that's a good spot to end this
episode because now i don't ever want to
take the last sip of anything that i
shared with anyone
oh my god uh okay guys thanks for
watching this episode on
uh
um but please follow jessly zama we're
gonna have all her socials down below is
there anything you want to promote
anything you want to say
uh i think we talked a lot about finding
the one and i think everything we said
here is uh communicate communicate
boundaries set boundaries systems for
committing yourself to forever
and then you'll be okay mm-hmm you're
gonna be okay okay and uh
don't cheer burritos okay make sure you
guys uh like give us five stars thumbs
up comment down below about how you feel
about [ __ ] burritos i don't know man
we just grossed out
something we're lonely leave us
something now i have in my brain is
saliva gina's single she needs something
to read give her a message this is true
all right we love you guys bye
[Music]
you